الى ملف حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا والتطورات
الميدانيه تحديدا في اقليم دنيسكو ومدينه
باخموتا التي تحاول القوات الروسيه
تطويقها وقد تفقد وزير الدفاع الروسي قوات
الشرق في محور الجنوب الدينيه في المقابل
قال قائد العمليات الخاصه في القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه ان قوات بلاده في
باخموت تعمل في ظرف ظرف شديده الصعوبان
التطورات تطلعون عليها من كرامه
سعود ومن دنيتك مراسل الجزيره امين درغامي
وابدا بك حسان
نعم عثمان قبل قليل اتينا من المنطقه
الواقعه غربيه منطقه بخموت وبالقرب من
مدينه شاسي فيار وكنا نرصد الحاله هناك
يبدو ان الحاله هي اشبه بمعركه
بكثافه بالقذائف بين الجانبين بين القوات
الروسيه التي تقصف تلك المنطقه بشده من
ثلاث اتجاهات مختلفه من الجنوب والشمال
والشرق اما القوات الاوكرانيه فانها ايضا
تكثف ضرباتها المدفعيه
والصاروخيه بكثافه باتجاه مواقع تمركز
القوات الروسيه لمنعها من التقدم
قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه كانت قد اكدت ان
القوات الروسيه تحاول ان تتقدم
وتحاول كذلك بكل الوسائل
فرض حصار
وتطويق مقاطعه او منطقه باخمت الا انها
تتصدى للهجمات الروسيه عند هذا المحور
وكذلك تقوم بقصف القوات الروسيه التي
تحاول التقدم قبل قليل فقط ايضا اكد رئيس
الاداره العسكريه في المنطقه الشرقيه
في حديث لقناه محليه ان الوضع في ضخمه هو
صعب للغايه لكنه تحت السيطره وفق تعبيره
وقبل قليل ايضا
ظهر احد الفيديوهات لاحد المقاتلين على
الجبهه بخموت داخل المدينه وهو يقول ان
القوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت في الداخل وما
زالت تعمل على مواجهه القوات الروسيه التي
تحاول التقدم نحو المدينه هذا كله يشير
الى الوضع هناك والى محاوله القوات
الاوكرانيه التصدي لمحاولات الهجوم التي
وصفتها قياده الاركان بانها كثيفه اشارت
الى 150 محاوله هجوم خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه
على يحاور الشرقيه هذا يضاف الى ان قائد
العمليات الخاصه الاوكرانيه كان قد زار
ايضا مدينه بخموت واكد على ان الوضع صعب
لكن القوات الاوكرانيه تتصدى لمحاوله
التقدم الروسيه كل ذلك يشير الى ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تريد ان تستمر في القتال وان
تحاول ان تحافظ على مواقعها فيما تبقى من
هذه المنطقه من مدينه باخموت هذه التطورات
ليست فقط هنا في الشرق انما ايضا في
الجنوبولوجيا وكريسون القصف يشتد على تلك
المناطق بالصواريخ وبالمدفعيه كذلك الحال
هناك في الشمال في خركيف نعم امين ما
المعلومات من الجانب الروسي
عثمان فيما يتعلق بباخ موت يبدو ان المهله
التي منحها
مؤسس شركه فارغنر الروسيه العسكريه امس
للقوات الاوكرانيه عبر ذلك الفيديو الذي
دعا من خلاله الرئيس الاوكراني الى سحب
القوات الاوكرانيه في غضون يوم او يومين
يبدو ان هذه المهله انتهت وعاده المعارك
الى حدتها في المناطق الشماليه الغربيه
بحسب موقع ريبارا العسكريه الان تتركز
المعارك حول الطريقه الاخير الذي يربط
ضخمه بالعالم الخارجي والذي يمر من بلده
خروموفا حديث عن ان هناك هجوم الان من قبل
قوات فاجنر على تلك البلده من اجل القطع
الفعلي لاخر طريق يؤدي الى ضخموت وبالتالي
حصار المدينه من جميع الطرق والالتفاف
عليها طبعا اذا نظرنا الى الخريطه الان
الحديث عن ان قوه فاكنار تتقدم من ثلاثه
اتجاهات من الشمال باتجاه الاح الشماليه
تحديدا المنطقه الصناعيه ومن الشرق الذي
كانت قد دخلت اليه قبل اشهر تحاول
الاقتراب من نهر بخمودكا ومن الجنوب
باتجاه حي الطيران وبالتالي تكون قوات اذا
اكملت هذه الحلقه
قد سيطرت بالكامل وقطعت كل الطرق والتفت
على المدينه وهو
النهجه الاستراتيجي الذي والتكتيك ايضا
العسكري الذي عودتنا عليه قوات فاجنر من
خلال معاركها السابقه سواء في
مقاطعه وايضا في سوليدار قبل نحو شهر ونصف
فهي تقوم اولا بقطع وتقطيع اوصال المدينه
قطع كل الطرق المؤديه منها واليها
وبالتالي تدفع القوات الاوكرانيه الى ترك
المدينه واخلائها لكن الان الحديث عن بقاء
بحسب طبعا التقديرات الروسيه نحو 2500
عسكري اوكراني داخل المدينه
السؤال المطروح لربما اذا ما تم قطع كلها
طرق وبالفعل محاصره هذه القوات داخل
بخموت ماء الخطوات اللاحقه هل سيتم اقتحام
المدينه القوات في الحقيقه لم تكن خلال
معاركها السابقه قد انتهجت مثل هذا تكتيك
لكن لربما الايام القليله المقبله ستجيب
على كل هذه التساؤلات بالنسبه لباقي
المحاور وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اليوم من
خلال بيانها اليومي تحدثت عن استهدافات
للقوات الاوكرانيه في محاور عده ابرزها في
كوبيانسك بمقاطعه ايضا في كراسني
بمقاطعه دونيسكو وفي جنوبها ايضا وقالت
بان عدد كبير من القوات الاوكرانيه قتل
قدرت ضحايا او خسائر القوات الاوكرانيه في
دونيسك فقط بنحو 500 في يوم واحد وتحدثت
ايضا عن اسقاط الثماني طائرات او عفوا
ثلاث مروحيات من طراز ثمانيه اوكرانيا
وتدمير عدد من الاليات فلنستمع الى ما
قاله المتحدث باسم الوزاره ايغور كانشينكو
في هذا السلط
في محور الايمان خسر العدو في هذه المنطقه
150 عسكريا في يوم واحد اضافه الى تدمير
مركبات قتاليه وفي محور دونيتسك تم القضاء
على نحو
4090 عسكريا اوكرانيا وتدمير مركبات
قتاليه وانظمه مدفعيه في يوم واحد
اذا شكرا جزيلا لكم من دنيتك من ضرغامي
ومن كرامات